tenemos aquí una forma de la ley
integrada de velocidad para reacciones
de primer orden y vamos a seguir
utilizando matemáticas y haciendo
cuentas y eventualmente vamos a hablar
acerca de la vida media tenemos por aquí
el logaritmo de la concentración de al
tiempo t - el logaritmo de la
concentración inicial de a y esto por
propiedades de los logaritmos es
exactamente igual al logaritmo natural
de la concentración de al tiempo t entre
la concentración de a el tiempo cero ok
eso es simplemente una de las
propiedades del logaritmo y esto es
igual a menos que te ok menos la
constante de velocidad de tu reacción
por el tiempo
ahora pues queremos deshacernos del
logaritmo natural entonces lo que vamos
a hacer es tomar e y elevarlo a
logaritmo natural de esta fracción y eso
tiene que ser igual a tomar e y elevarlo
a la menos k t entonces si tomamos e y
lo elevamos a logaritmo natural de esta
fracción nos queda simplemente esta
fracción así es que tenemos la
concentración de a al tiempo t entre la
concentración inicial de a y tenemos que
es igual a el elevado a la menos acá
y ahora vamos a multiplicar de los dos
lados del igual por la concentración
inicial de a entonces tenemos que la
concentración de al tiempo t es igual en
la concentración inicial de a por el ala
menos que de y ya que llegamos a esta
fórmula es muchísimo más fácil pensar en
la gráfica de la concentración de a con
respecto al tiempo entonces en el eje de
las
vamos a poner la concentración de iu en
el eje de las equis vamos a poner el
tiempo y entonces estamos graficando la
concentración de a conforme pasa el
tiempo y bueno como podemos observar lo
que tenemos aquí es un decaimiento
exponencial porque la concentración de a
con respecto al tiempo se comporta como
una a la menos el tiempo por algunas
constantes y por aquí ya dibujé una
gráfica de un decaimiento exponencial
entre ellas si se ve la gráfica del
decaimiento exponencial
entonces si por ejemplo tomamos este
punto lo obtenemos cuando el tiempo es
exactamente igual a cero entonces si en
esta fórmula sustituimos t por cero lo
que obtenemos es la concentración
inicial de a que la tenemos aquí por el
ala menos k por cero porque tenemos el
tiempo igual a cero por cero
y al acero es simplemente un 1 y
entonces este punto es la concentración
de a cuando el tiempo es igual a 0 en
fin como podemos observar en esta
gráfica entre más aumentamos el tiempo
más decrece la concentración de a al
tiempo t y esta es la forma en la que
decrece una exponencial y además sabemos
que conforme el tiempo tiende a infinito
la concentración de a en ese tiempo
tiende a cero y podemos ver que estos
puntos están cada vez más cerca del cero
pero nunca llega a tocarlo porque ella
sí es que conforme el tiempo aumenta la
concentración de a se acerca al cero
pero nunca lo toca simplemente se acerca
cada vez más y ese es el chiste del
decaimiento exponencial bueno ahora sí
vamos a pensar en la vida media tenemos
una definición por aquí que nos dice que
la vida media
es el tiempo que se tarda la
concentración de un reactivo en decrecer
a la mitad de la concentración inicial
entonces pues tenemos la concentración
inicial de un reactivo y la vida media
es cuánto tiempo nos tardamos en que la
concentración inicial se reduzca a la
mitad así es que lo que vamos a hacer es
tomar esto de aquí y colocarlo por acá y
luego el tiempo que nos interesa el
tiempo que estamos tratando de encontrar
es la vida media que generalmente se
describe como una t de tiempo y por aquí
un medio y entonces vamos a sustituir
esta incógnita en nuestra fórmula pues
vamos a despejar la vida media por aquí
en la izquierda al tiempo de la vida
media tenemos que la concentración de a
la concentración inicial de a sobre 2 y
eso es igual a la concentración inicial
de a por el ala menos k por la vida
media ahora necesitamos más espacio aquí
lo que podemos hacer es cancelar la
concentración inicial de los dos lados y
entonces nos queda que un medio es igual
a la menos que por la vida media y ahora
necesitamos deshacernos de esta
exponencial entonces vamos a sacar el
logaritmo natural de los dos lados
y tomamos el logaritmo natural de esto
de aquí y tomamos el logaritmo natural
de un medio logaritmo natural y
exponencial se cancelan porque son
funciones inversas y lo que nos queda es
que el logaritmo natural de un medio es
igual a menos que por la vida media y
pues estamos tratando de despejar a t un
medio entonces dividimos entre menos acá
y nos queda que t un medio que es la
vida media es igual a menos el logaritmo
natural de un medio entre acá bueno y
entonces vamos a sacar la calculadora y
ponemos logaritmo natural de puntos 5 y
nos salen menos punto 69 3 y la vida
media es igual a 0.69 3
/ ka que es la constante de velocidad de
la reacción esta es la vida media de una
reacción de primer orden ahora aquí hay
una cosa que tenemos que observar que es
súper interesante e importante y es que
pues bueno la constante de velocidad de
la reacción es una constante y por aquí
este número de aquí también es una
constante así es que la vida media es
una constante y no depende para nada de
la concentración inicial y eso pasa pues
porque aquí se cancelarán las
concentraciones iniciales y bueno eso no
sucede con todos los órdenes de reacción
pero si pasa para todas las reacciones
de primer orden la vida media de
cualquier reacción de primer orden es
una constante no depende de la
concentración inicial y ahora vamos a
pensar qué es lo que significa esto para
una reacción en un ejemplo como el que
tenemos aquí
que hay digamos que tenemos una reacción
por aquí y voy a representar esta
concentración inicial con 8 puntos 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8
ok entonces tenemos aquí nuestra
concentración inicial y vamos a esperar
el tiempo que sea necesario hasta que la
concentración haya disminuido a la mitad
entonces para ese momento habremos
perdido a la mitad de nuestro reactivo
entonces nada más tendremos cuatro
puntitos y nos podemos preguntar dónde
se encuentra ese momento en nuestra
gráfica así es que nos fijamos en este
punto de aquí esta es nuestra
concentración inicial de ocho puntitos
este es el eje de las concentraciones y
tenemos la mitad de la concentración
inicial así es que estamos más o menos
por aquí y entonces nos vamos a la
gráfica y encontramos este punto de aquí
ahora bajamos una línea recta nuestro
eje x que nos dice los tiempos esto de
aquí nos dice que obtenemos esta
concentración en este tiempo y bueno
pongamos algunos tiempos por aquí
digamos que estos son 10 segundos 20
segundos 30 segundos 40 y 50 entonces lo
que podemos observar aquí es que nos
tardamos 10 segundos en disminuir la
concentración de a exactamente a la
mitad aunque la primera vida media es de
10 segundos escribamos lo por aquí
tenemos que la primera vida media es
igual a 10 segundos y lo repito esta
reacción me la acabo de inventar para
explicar el concepto de vida media pero
bueno entonces ahora tenemos cuatro
puntitos y nos podemos preguntar por
cuánto tiempo se van a tardar estos
puntitos en que la mitad de ellos
reaccione y se vuelva un producto que
hay cuánto tiempo nos vamos a tardar
en tener la mitad de los reactivos o sea
en tener dos reactivos y lo que hacemos
es ir a la gráfica que hay por aquí
ahora esta es la concentración inicial y
la mitad de la concentración inicial
está por aquí así es que nos vamos a la
curva encontramos este punto de aquí y
vemos en qué tiempo sucede esto y cuánto
tiempo nos tardamos en decrecer la
concentración de a a la mitad y otra vez
fueron 10 segundos así es que esta vida
media también fueron 10 segundos y lo
podemos volver a hacer ok
cuánto tiempo nos tardaremos en que
decrezca la concentración inicial de dos
puntitos a la mitad de la concentración
o sea un puntito nos fijamos en donde
está la concentración inicial queremos
buscar la mitad de la concentración
buscamos el puntito en la gráfica a esta
altura osea este punto de aquí
dejemos la perpendicular al eje de las
equis y obtenemos el tiempo y como
podemos observar otra vez fueron 10
segundos entonces la vida media es otra
vez 10 segundos como observamos cuando
estábamos haciendo las cuentas y como
podemos observar en esta gráfica y en
este ejercicio de aquí la vida media es
independiente de la concentración
inicial
no importa si empezamos con 8 partículas
o 4 o 2 la vida media es siempre la
misma ok eso es lo que pasa con la vida
media de las reacciones de primer orden